andy katz NBA draft analyst is joining
us NBA TV they have the expanded draft
night coverage along with Tom Penn Steve
Smith Brendan Heyward they'll be getting
ready to get started Thursday at 7:00
Eastern NBA TV
Andy joins us now what do you make of
that discussion we just had there Andy
well I was hopefully let me jump in Dan
and great to hear your voice and great
to be on with you again here's the deal
Zion Williamson is a personality and he
embraces it and he is going to be a
marketing just I think the marketing
icon of this group over the next couple
of years and so if I'm the Orleans
I'm coveting a player like this and
nothing against the Anthony Davis
because we are you know we started to
see him more and advertisements and
things like that but Diane Williamson
has a magnetic smile people are drawn to
him and so for franchise like New
Orleans you know that's like the Lakers
you don't needed that as much as there
because there's so much about the Lakers
in LA and all that but for New Orleans
you need someone people are going to
gravitate to ya and Diane Williamson
will do that there isn't like I thought
it was ridiculous at any point during
the regular season went to board
debating if there was gonna be someone
else because no owner would turn him
down because she's good people in the
seats he's going to be greatly community
go do all the ads you need for you and
just I think that he's the guy that you
want that's your franchise now is he
gonna help you win more than quite
Leonard no I you know for what that
franchise needs right now in terms of
attention and everything else that comes
with that he's the right fit is there a
chance John Marant and/or RJ Barrett
will be recognized as better than Zion
Williamson in ten years five years yes
no question about it like that's the
thing where I was at the lottery and you
know the groaning that you can hear in
Chicago from New York about not getting
number one well yes star values
we'll deliver that you know at Madison
Square Garden but RJ buried people
forget he was the number one text
projected number one before that
Kentucky game in November so New York
still getting a number one talent John
Moran you know yes he was sort of came
lately in terms of this position but
anyone who watched him during the season
you saw what he did against Marquette
with a triple-double he has the
potential to deliver kind of like what
Damian Lillard did for Portland where
people didn't know who he was he comes
out and he's got a team you know years
later that's got a chance to get to the
finals and you know obviously reach the
Western Conference Finals but John Moran
you know can can potentially do
something like that for a franchise like
Memphis and be that kind of chance you
know transcend additional player that
can help a franchise get over the hump
for you know years from now where does
the draft begin to go off the rails
tomorrow night well right at 4:00
because while we've had years before
with a consensus one in between this
year and LeBron you can go to Anthony
Davis John Wall Blake Griffin you know
there's been other players that I think
we could say unequivocally were the
number John dirt roads when he was going
to Chicago so I'd say those four in
between LeBron and Diane Williamson but
I don't know I don't remember a year
where we know unequivocally where we
knew unequivocally one two three like we
do tomorrow night but at 4:00 now with
the Lakers stick going to New Orleans
and we'll New Orleans keep it
that's where everything really starts
because it could be Jared Culver it
could be hundred hunter
it could be Kobe white area startling
you know any one of those guys could be
there like to be on the move and
everything after that is going to have
to react quickly within that five minute
window to go off of that because I don't
think that any of these teams
unequivocally know exactly who's going
to be at their spot I think there's
gonna be a lot of movement poor on down
yeah I'm curious we're talking to Andy
Katz NBA TV NBA draft analyst and I look
at the pelicans at four and who covets
that spot if they want to get Garland
the point guard out of
by the way you know we we have this all
the time using in football where there's
somebody or a couple players that all of
a sudden somebody goes look out here
they come and then they start moving up
what exactly Garlan just got healthy I
guess and she didn't play that but it's
almost like he became more coveted
because there's a mystery surrounding
him we weren't quite sure exactly who he
is or what he is but he's not you know
lacking confidence he said he's the best
point guard in the draft what do you
make of this meteoric rise with his kid
well I think you have to wait and see I
mean first of all had he played
Vanderbilt would not have been over 19
the SEC I don't think would've been a
tournament team but they certainly would
have been a team of people to talk about
more we would have seen much more of
them now you can be critical and I think
that's a fair thing that he then bolted
and did his own thing and wanted to make
sure he was healthy for this moment for
the drought you know we can look at
players like even Zion who came back
from his injury or PJ Washington who
still played in the tournament when he
didn't know if he was going to play when
he got heard now you could say oh look
you've got so much later in the season
you can't really fail on your team that
late when you're into the NCAA
tournament but Darius Carlin he was
recruited to Vanderbilt and he got hurt
and decided you know what I'm now only
going to take care of myself and then he
leaves so then he does that and he sort
of out of sight out of mind
he was obviously one of the best point
guards coming into the year and now that
he says and I interviewed him as well in
Chicago and yes and thinks he's the best
point guard and probably thinks that he
should be higher than John Moran I don't
think he will be but you know at the
ends up going at number four and whether
he stays there gets shipped that would
be meteoric rise and we have to just
wait and see if you know he was correct
on bacon on himself and taking himself
sort of out of action and just sort of
doing his own thing over the last five
months yeah but you have a team that
already has a point guard they already
have a backcourt in New Orleans and if
Garland's there it feels like New
Orleans is gonna offer up that pick for
somebody would that be logical no you're
right but that's why you know we heard
talk to all the four going for the eight
and ten with Atlanta
and that would make that would not make
sense if they selected garland for that
trade because you're a young in Atlanta
so if he goes for then I do think he's
on the move but maybe somewhere else I
think that New Orleans has a great shot
to get someone of value if they don't
take him and were to take Jarrett Oliver
or DeAndre hunter what I love about
those two guys is they embrace defense
they love to defend and so they've got a
skill that immediately can transfer to
the NBA and going in as a rookie they're
not gonna complain or anything like that
they want to defend their offensive
games got better and better throughout
their careers in the NCAA and will only
get better Kolber you know first two
years first player Texas second score of
a thousand points sometimes he
disappeared but he was a timely shooter
statistically didn't always look that
way but he made the right shots and
Hunter everyone remember he did not play
against UMBC he was hurt and he's
healthy this past year and I'm not
saying that's the reason but they win
the national championship so you've got
tremendous value I think that's a better
pick to go it certainly Moreland keep
the pick I think they should go either
Culver or hunter is there a chance John
Marant
is better more talented than Zion
Williamson well I mean the difference so
could he have more staying power and be
like a Lillard sure you know you
certainly could do that and could
Williamson ultimately you know not not
be the dominant player that he is in
college of course you could I mean he
basically played bully ball because he
could in college basketball he just was
a freak athletically that no one could
defend a normal is gonna stand in front
of until maybe ran into taco fall would
you not get a Pinot so that was sort of
the anomaly and that that's not going to
happen in the NBA because it's much more
physical there's much more size so
someone like John Moran can get around
that he can fly over people and
yeah I mean I think there's a chance
that we could be talking more about him
years from now but I still say the giant
woman has the personality and maybe John
rate will grow into it because he's not
as much of an extrovert but he's really
started to embrace it because you know
he was not overly recruited he had there
you've got that chip that edge because
he went to a place like Murray and had
to prove himself and when I'm
interviewed of my sense of a young man
who was starting to find himself
starting to feel more comfortable in the
public space where Zion has been in that
arena for quite some time so I think
Jacque could evolve into that kind of
player that becomes much more of a
faceless franchise and one of the faces
of the NBA I'll leave you with this the
discipline there's disappointment and
then there's bust now bust is extreme
like Anthony Bennett would be a bust
marquel Foltz right now is a bust
Greg Oden because he got injured I guess
is a bus Kwame Brown was a bust Michael
all of a Candie might be more of a
disappointment than a bust
but how high up in the drought like at
what point can you not become a bust
because you got drafted at six or set
like a basta is usually one or two isn't
it
yeah I mean you're forgetting one of the
all-time boss and Darko Miletich so I
had number two yeah yeah number cuing so
what happened in that draft no three so
yeah I mean for me it's got to be
somewhere in that top five after that
especially now when there's so many
young players you know it's hard to Dean
someone a bust and you know there's a
lot of chatter about whether you know
cam radish will heat pan out and and I
said this I think he's sort of like the
fifth Beatle the guy that got lost in
the shuffle
among all the other players because he's
not very outspoken and didn't sort of
seek that kind of limelight and was not
as but as much in the inner circle buddy
group as ioan and RJ but if he goes you
know somewhere in the seven to ten range
that's one opps bet he doesn't pan out I
don't that fair to say that he didn't
work out and was a boss because you
didn't end up going out in the top three
now if
all this heisted were talking with John
Maria and he completely you know flames
out then yes then that would be a fair
assessment but beyond I'd say four or
five I don't know if that's there Andy
good to talk to you have fun tomorrow
night and during free agency we
appreciate your time as always
that's andy katz NBA draft analyst and
NBA TV's expanded draft night coverage
so Tom Penn Steve Smith
Brendan Heyward and others Thursday at
7:00 Eastern NBA TV also offering 30
hours of around-the-clock NBA free
agency coverage beginning Thursday June
27th and continuing daily through
Thursday July 4th for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]